Doja cat reveals she got plastic surgery
I'm very very excited the singer shares
the news on Twitter writing in true Doja
fashion got my teeth done and my
bedazzled I'm obsessed the Grammy winner
says she got a breast reduction and is
now a size 32c it's not too crazy Doja
explains that she got the procedures
done a week ago and is feeling okay amid
her recovery adding I got lipo so my
thighs hurt a lot if I move too much but
I'm healing really fast Doja says
getting back to normal will take about
three months oh no oh no are you kidding
me as for why well Doja told fans about
her surgery plans back in November and
explained I just want my teeth pulled up
because some of my tops don't fit the
way I want them to of course the
singer's been known to change up her
look I just can't believe that it took
me this long to be like shave your head
last year she debuted a buzzed head and
shaved off her eyebrows on Instagram
live I feel like I I was never supposed
to have hair anyway
I like don't like having hair I never
liked having hair
I cannot tell you one time since the
beginning of my life that I've ever been
like this is cool and she saved it all
off Charlie Brown with it and earlier
this year Doja attended Paris Fashion
Week wearing lots of uniquely placed
fake eyelashes
creating makeshift brows a mustache and
even some chin hair with the falsies
it's giving face and that's it Doja
teased the look on Instagram writing if
lashes are what you want then lashes are
what you'll get
thank you very much a few days earlier
Doja stepped out to the scalparelli show
covered in 30 000 hand-placed Swarovski
Crystals the transformation took a
whopping five hours
[Music]
but it seems there's a lot of new in
doja's life at the moment as fans
eagerly anticipate her next album
thank you
why don't you say so she tweeted Tuesday
DC4 has a title now and while she didn't
confirm anything officially she left us
with a cryptic mention of the hashtag
hellmouth she also changed her username
[Music]
foreign